my host and presenter for undercover
alphabetes events but nobody knows I did
my masters nobody knows I do undergrad
nobody knows I'm a stem student and I'm
a BSC and I'm Australia geek no one
knows that no one cares for that no one
asks that was a fun fact why didn't you
say it because it's boring because it's
boring
who is it boring for yeah
maybe that's the same thing Lisa was
saying exactly modern people think he's
boring I find that I find it really
fascinating and that for me that's
something you should lead with that's
true guys
more special that is something be
careful makes you in the truck everybody
that is something no no everybody
exactly but at the same time as a black
woman and you're now what you're
educated double educated you're you know
this or that you want to be used care
man away guys I want to get married
no no but that's what Society no that's
what society makes you
scared by that unless you act like
you're better than them because of it no
but thank you no man no an average guy
can beat you up no man is intimidated by
you no not physically not physically but
I have had people no people come to me
and tell me they're intimidated
and I look at them and I'm like excuse
me they're not the ones for you no of
course they're not you can't be
intimidated with me
I love my energy but when women say this
to you that what does that typically
mean well it means like she's she's mad
egotistical when they say like Mana
intimidated it might be this and that
and it's men judge you by your body
language and like how feminine you are
and so if if God is looking at you being
like I'm intimidated because of like a
degree or something like that I've never
met a guy who gave a flying [ __ ] yeah
anything no one ever no one cares I
think it's the top people that say that
are always people who behave in a way
that creates that image then they say oh
it's because I'm a woman because I'm
this and that that's my experience no
okay but I'm saying to you that I don't
wake up like this okay I came here even
just be myself not here as in here here
to the UK in general even the way I
speak because I speak with an Italian
mentality to say it's rude it's too
strong it's too forward
a lot of people don't cannot work with
that you understand I'm not saying that
I'm intimidating I'm saying I'm being
told I'm intimidated I don't think I am
not the numbers
if you understand enough that it's like
part of your Italian habits it habits
from another language then surely you
can just like you know solve a value and
be like all right I'll adjust there's a
lot of Italians there who manage to not
be seen as rude it's very difficult it's
not it's not you see now it's adjusting
yourself so I have to be myself have
self-love and stay at the same time I
just myself like this is why this
Society is going to Baba this is another
policy I happen to be myself I
appreciate myself have self-care but
sometimes I need to adjust I don't
understand that's a fallacy do not
suggest somebody
now when you're saying about the Italian
news I've got money in front of she's
Italian yeah and she's the most calmest
car no no no about
is that by no difference I'm just
talking about adjusting yourself as an
Italian yeah because Italian is who you
are the culture and all of the the
fieriness is something that can be toned
down so that's what I'm asking about
what is it about your Italian
intimidating sometimes it's also
original Regional people from like the
South or from Rome and stuff sometimes a
bit different but it's just how the tone
of voice comes out is not really what
I'm saying
I can speak to me a lot of Italian
people say I'm passionate when they do
yeah yeah and people will take that the
wrong way as arrogant ignorant loud but
I just think they're passionate yeah
exactly that's exactly that's exactly
but but I think I think that's like a
lack of femininity that's like I think
like typically when when I hear a girl
say this and some some behavior that
they do that's like a lack of femininity
to men and that's what's putting them
off well I've never heard that before
I'm absolutely
no no in the sense
myself even what she said like and this
is someone like I can be loud too I'm
not I'm not above it but I'm I'm just
saying like when when she said like loud
like the the traits that Auntie just
used that that's not none of them are
feminine traits and so men don't
typically like loud girls you know I was
me I I talk a lot okay My Italian Friend
my Italian friend's been married for
years she's gone in and she's Italian
and I've never heard her razor I've
never heard her razor telling the voice
yeah she is just so humbling she is just
so
feminine her and her husband
I don't know they're just perfect
together he looks at her like every time
he sees her I look at him they live
together they've been together for years
and they've got free people and he looks
at her like as if it was the first day
he met her when he looks at her he's in
La it's like the love is in there and
when I'll see her and she's only tiny
and when I'll see you in a little
trainers and I say to her hey are you
looking what's your husband saying
because you're losing a bit of weight
you're looking a bit sexy she's 55. that
was when I made a birthday cake for and
her and her husband even though they're
both Italian they're the most
humbles most quietest most
undercover sexiest people thank you they
know undercover sexy because you can
just see that they've got that sexiness
deep inside of them
um I do want to add quickly though that
that fallacy is that's a fallacy and I
see this a lot in the black community
where you know a lot of the time
black women and a lot of black community
know up the pain points and
communication and there's always a
defensive kind of like oh it's
self-editing you know if if I kind of
calm myself down and understand this
that it's me not loving myself and
there's all this pushback and you
realize feminine women don't really do
that like feminine women like watch
their calm they're very careful with
their tone you know they fit into every
conversation and I think that's
something as a community we need to we
need to promote that those kind of
values like you can be a classy black
woman who's not loud who's kind of you
know Suave about how you engage yourself
it's not it doesn't mean you're not you
don't love yourself
the modern women want to have some of
that then they should do what I do and
mix with because I I find that a lot of
people who have negative
ideas about marriage is because they
have no positive role models of marriage
and if they even if they nowadays I've
realized that modern people even if
their parents are together and they
parents have like they're still married
they're looking at their parents
relationship or something negative when
it should be something you know they
might think oh my dad tells my mum what
to do or my mom was just a housewife and
they've seen it as something negative
where it's something positive so me
personally when I now even though I'm
I'm content with my man I still surround
myself with happily married feminine
women and their husbands and their
families because I sort of I'm like a
sponge I just want to jump in the middle
and soak it all up yeah I tell you I'm
gonna do that as well okay
um I'm gonna it's gonna kind of late so
I'm gonna
um take a second to read Super Chat and
then we're gonna do final thoughts so
anything you want to speak your piece on
um don't don't go on too long you know
but we're we're gonna give you a chance
to speak at the end so
um thank you guys for all of the
donations this show um it really helps
us fund the new camera that we're trying
to get we're trying to shoot in 8k
um blessing are we gonna be able to
stream an 8K at some point
oh no okay it's just it's for reaction
videos
um I really want to be able to see the
freckles on my face when I do reactions
I don't have a lot I have a few though
and I feel like yeah it's gonna be cool
okay and we're just doing the 10 or more
um I also heard you guys that you want
uh as many of you know I was just banned
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible